in berlin konnte ein päckchen an unseren
bundespräsidenten
der heißt frank walter steinmeier nicht
ausgeliefert werden ja wahre geschichte
auf dem zettel des paketboten stand der
empfänger war nicht zu ermitteln namen
nicht auf klingel oder briefkasten vom
schloss bellevue und der frank walter
ist kein einzelfall immer mehr deutsche
klagen in diesen tagen über paketsendung
die nicht ankommen oder viel zu spät
ankommen
allerdings hat das gründe die
arbeitsbedingungen bei den zusteller
firmen sind inzwischen so katastrophal
dass die kaum noch personal film
meistens nur noch bulgaren rumänen
moldawien die extra dafür über geholt
werden die kein wort deutsch sprechen
wozu das führen kann zeigt diese
benachrichtigungskarte das paket wurde
beim nachbarn namens keine werbung
abgegeben
hammer
das ist ja
das ist ja lustig meine nachbarn heißen
auch keine werbung
ja da sieht man zwar wieder die
ausländer nehmen uns die arbeitsplätze
weg die wir nicht haben wollen und das
elend in der paketbranche wird wirklich
immer schlimmer für viele zusteller
bleiben mit glück mit glück sechs euro
50 die stunde
dass der unter dem mindestlohn ja das
ist unter dem mindestlohn
da müssen sie aber ein wirklich gutes
gebiet haben wenn sie einen land gebiet
haben dann werden sie sechs euro 50
niemals bekommen nie sondern drei
zwischen drei und vier euro
das nenne ich meinen echten horrorgenre
die nacht der lebenden boten übrigens
die fortsetzung des schockers amazon bis
aber das wusste sie
und leider macht auch unsere gute alte
post mit beim fröhlichen ausbeuten vor
allem seit die post tochter dhl vor drei
jahren 49 einzelgesellschaften gegründet
hat die sich nicht mehr am post
tarifverträge halten müssen
die post bei der ja immer noch der staat
mit drin sitzt hat letztes jahr auch
dank lohndumping ein gewinn von 3,74
milliarden euro gemacht und dhl erwartet
für weihnachten einen neuen paket rekord
wie schön waren dürfen subunternehmen
weiter sklaven halten
ich erinnere an die worte dieses
sprechenden streifenhörnchen
wir haben klar verabredet dass wir
gleichen lohn für gleiche arbeit machen
und da keine schlupflöcher mehr zu
lassen keine schlupflöcher durch das
schlupfloch passende jahr ein
lieferwagen
in der fleischbranche gibt es übrigens
eine konzern haftung für die
arbeitsbedingungen bei subunternehmen in
der logistikbranche leider immer noch
nicht weil keine ahnung ich glaube das
gesetz war in der post aber dann war der
empfänger nicht zu hause
deswegen bleiben die armen zusteller in
deutschland im weitesten sinne
prostituierte schade schade
fast nirgends in europa ist pakete
verschicken so wenig wie bei uns und
gerade weil die post so ein ausbeuter
laden ist sagt der post chef appel und
deswegen lohnt es sich ohne zweifel
aktionär dieses unternehmens zu sehen
absolut freunde übrigens ein paket
fahrer hat neulich versucht den
mindestlohn für sich einzuklagen was
immerhin zu einem vergleich mit der l
geführt hat man munkelt im fünfstelligen
bereich
das nur als kleiner tipp für alle
zusteller die uns jetzt gucken im
übrigen muss man fairerweise sagen der
konzern tut ja was für seine leute
[Musik]
er ist leiter des neu eröffneten dhl
therapiezentrums in bonn
er kümmert sich um paketzusteller die
dem klub psychisch nicht mehr gewachsen
sprich ein riesenproblem ja immer mehr
menschen die für die post arbeiten
leiden unter posttraumatischen
belastungsstörung durch sein können
schlimm schlimm da ist es aber auch
breithardt oder wie ich immer sage jeder
hat sein päckchen zu tragen
ich hab ihm gesagt bei den dort päckchen
das macht schon viele fertig ich muss
einfach aufhören immer wieder päckchen
zusammen jetzt habe ich auch wieder
pixel
in der therapie lernen die patienten in
praktischen übungen welche tricks beim
zustellen wirklich zeit sparen
[Musik]
apa
die versuchte therapeut seinen
krankgeschriebenen schützling wieder in
den harten arbeitsalltag zurückzuführen
wie bewertest du musst du wollen
ja ich weiß das klingt für den laien
etwas hart aber ich muss sie jetzt
einfach gesund kriegen ja weil wir
brauchen den trottel fürs
weihnachtsgeschäft
[Musik]
der typ ist durch das ist nicht mehr
therapierbar
wir müssen raus musste leider in solchen
fällen gibt es nur eine lösung
wir stecken die user in einen karton und
schicken hinzu
wir haben es uns sehr gut gefallen da
warst du noch beschissener behandelt die
bei uns sind sie geliefert
[Applaus]
[Musik]